any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable in magic
hello everyone this is Bryan Keating
your fearful host of the into the
impossible podcast the production of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at the university of
california san diego it's a pleasure to
welcome back our guest Eric Weinstein
this is actually part 2 of an interview
we recorded back in May of 2020 early
May of 2020 and it's just impossible to
overstate how much has happened in the
past few weeks since part 1 was released
and now in June of 2020 I had originally
hoped to release this episode segment
part 2 on Father's Day because of all
the very interesting advice and insights
that and wisdom that Erik shares in this
episode as you're about to hear but Eric
kind of beat me to it in that he
actually interviewed his son an earlier
episode on the portal podcast which I am
a religious subscriber to and I
recommend that you do as well and
speaking of religion this podcast will
cover some of his insights into rituals
and our shared religious practices in
some sense and where we differ in
religion along with such notables as sam
Harris and folks like Sascha Segan we've
had on the show and I want to encourage
people to continue giving Eric's work
its fair share its attention that it's
due whether or not you think it is
ultimately correct he's certainly an
extremely deep thinker and he has a
tremendous amount of wisdom which is a
rare commodity to offer time will tell
if he's correct and I think it's
fascinating always to spend time with
him
I encourage you to check him out of
course his podcast needs no introduction
from me to you but I do recommend it
with my highest recommendation so with
that I will ask you to sit back enjoy
this episode of into the impossible if
you would do us a big favor and leave a
rating and review on iTunes
leave a comment and a thumbs up
subscribe notification bell whatever
else youtube allows you to do watch in
three dimensions maybe that will be very
much appreciated as always that's sort
of the secret sauce in this podcasting
world and lastly I asked you to
subscribe to my newsletter to get show
notes from this episode and others we've
had on some really spectacular guests
and we're gonna have on some even more
guests even more spectacular guests not
that they're more spectacular but
there's going to be an increased number
of spectacular guests including none
other than Jim Simon's in his very first
and maybe only podcast that he's ever
done I'm quite proud to say that he sat
down with me for over an hour and a half
and we talked a lot about life and that
will be our Father's Day episode for
2020 we had a Mother's Day episode with
Sascha Segan I've also interviewed her
mother Andrew Ian and look for those
episodes to be coming out so please
subscribe like rate comment do
everything you can do I don't know I
don't know what else to do but we really
appreciate you out there
give me some recommendations for people
you'd like to have a Michonne
conversation and now I turn it over to
none of them dr. herb Weinstein and
myself and part two of a very
fascinating and wide-ranging
conversation on life the universe
religion God extraterrestrials and
everything else in between what what do
you believe
Eric Weinstein University would look
like how would you how would you redo it
and but what I meant before by the
thousand year old tradition certainly
not peer review it's certainly not you
know the department structure that we
have but basically education is more or
less unchanged it's a time of the
University of ellonija in 1080 sage on a
stage except back then I always point
out that students could go on strike and
the professors wouldn't get paid we
don't have any of that nowadays but at
Weinstein you how how would things be
different and and what kinds of of
novelty or injection into the Academy
would you provide because I believe
we're in peril especially due to kovat I
think I think our current model I think
people at universities are blissfully
unaware of how short our days are going
to be if we
don't embrace new modalities not just a
cultural and and then and the and the
very punishing vindictiveness of that
you've experienced perhaps but but how
would you run it how would you run as
the Provost Chancellor of Boeing Stein
University first of all look over your
right shoulder you know right shoulders
over here yes well down okay lately I
thought it was your other shoulder this
is right okay so look over your left
shoulder okay
the Klein model yes but by an advertiser
well actually you gave free advertising
to these Klein bottles than you and I
bought about ten of them fantastic I
would have people in direct contact with
Wonder and I would have a curriculum
based on Wonder and transcendence
because even if you're a physicist you
need to know about C elegans hmm you
know you need to know about the protein
folding problem you need to know how the
International phonemic alphabet is
generated from the vocal apparatus in
the human vocal tract all of these
things that we don't teach because we
don't have a modern concept of what our
greatest hits are so you should be able
to take the Grand Tour somebody who
isn't a physicist needs to know that a
weight going up an inclined plane is not
fundamental to physics but a weight on a
spring you can tell the world from a
weight on the spring although I had a
wonderful conversation with Mario Livio
who's the author of many books including
is God a mathematician but his latest
book is about Galileo and how Galileo
faced the science deniers it's called
that Galilei on the science deniers and
in it I had a conversation with him
about curiosity which was the subject of
his previous book called why and exactly
what you're saying
teaching wonder teaching but I actually
said we should teach the inclined plane
even though I've never used it once in
my entire life as a physicist but the
reason we should teach it is we should
teach the controversy that it emerged
from the
outcome of him being imprisoned for
heresy and why that came about why ideas
are dangerous and threaten institutions
gates of institutional narratives that
you talked about and I think actually it
does have value but it has value in a
way that we wouldn't think but we don't
teach our physics majors and I
understand what you're saying I'm just
trying to say that yeah life is short
yeah and the key problem that I'm having
is that taste is not being weaponized
properly as a mode of instruction mm-hmm
so for example the Antikythera mechanism
is really really important cephalopods
are really important and then some
people say well I don't understand why
not nudie bras you know and the answer
is no so cool pods are much more
important because it's an incredible
level of intelligence develop very far
away in the fellow genetic tree so
you're asking about Eric Weinstein
University which doesn't exist prob
probably thank God but the key point is
is that it would be extolling you know
everybody would learn the rudiments of
Hamiltonian dynamics the hamiltonian
recipe and the fiber bundles the spring
because that particular example because
of its oscillatory nature sort of
globalizes to everything he would be
trying to give people the highest impact
knowledge that they could possibly carry
around in their heads and then unpack it
will rather than this sort of you know
yesterday with sort of the political
economy of teaching whatever the field
knows to be the right way of thinking it
usually reserves for very late in the
game you see this with children's
educational this year we're going to do
pond scum and then next year we're gonna
do plants and then the next year we're
gonna do animals in ecologist for God's
sakes start with natural and sexual
selection and then apply it everywhere
you know talk about you know the the
molecular basis of the genetic code the
central dogma in the history you know
you use the eighth day of creation by
and is your text or something like this
but all sorts of genius-level stuff to
do to make the world come alive and be
vivid that doesn't involve boring people
and making them sit through a million
lessons until they finally get to the
goods yeah mm-hmm with every tenure at
Weinstein University hell yes yeah okay
great well not only tenure yeah there
would be luxury hmm because luxury is
actually like if you consume luxury
you're a net glutton we sort of but the
purpose of luxury is to it has an
evolutionary purpose in it which is it
tells your brain that it is safe to
think to dream to experiment but if what
you do is just use it to show off then
you know you're basically popping
platinum foil bonbons in your mouth and
you're useless to everyone there's a
reason for example that a place like it
my tea or Harvard might have a cottage
for retreats you know I remember
visiting Raoul bought in his home and
Martha's Vineyard and you know
sunbathing and skinny-dipping with him
as we discussed the mysteries of the
universe it's very important that
professors in reasonable subjects go
send their kids to the same schools as
the movers and shakers of business and
nobody likes to hear this the
mismanagement of our academics so that
we we've become lesser members of
society and the thing that really struck
me at some point was when I was in
finance in New York somebody said you
know get me two PhDs I thought what okay
so that's like a commodity like egghead
I'm like fungible they're fungible -
right so slightly different than
yesterday as I said I talked to Carl
Sagan's daughter Sascha Segan she has a
book called for small creatures such as
we and it's a book about rituals
ironically and in the last three
conversations I've had with other
intellectuals like Sasha have been about
rituals in some form or another Dave
Rubin was on the podcast not too long
ago Michael Shermer before that and in
all cases we talked about various
rituals maybe it's the academic ritual
in the case of Michael Shermer or with
Dave Rubin it's sort of this notion of
of the Sabbath and and he takes this
digital detox I mean he's Jewish but
he's not observant in any way but he he
takes a digital detox Sasha it's
literally you know finding rituals that
are secular to answer the question that
has plagued you know many people can you
be spiritual with that religion and I
wonder you know you're you're obviously
Israel and Judaism is an important
component of your life you lived in
Israel you were postdoc in Israel can
you talk a little bit about rituals that
you observe where they fit in importance
do they have a place at the intellectual
table are they a byproduct of a bygone
era where do they fit in in your life
rituals maybe even in your work habits
and how you do what you do so more or
less maybe we screw up five times a year
we've had Shabbat dinner every Friday
night in my family since my daughter was
born 17 years ago so that's incredibly
powerful and I don't think we should shy
away from religion mm-hmm yeah I don't
think that means that we should believe
in God necessarily I'm perfectly happy
with being religious and being material
I think you know so yeah I would say you
know at least at most believe in one God
you know I do feel like there is even in
Sasha's book and I kind of didn't
I called it out but but I this is saying
you know is there a danger you know cuz
her books about the seasons and that
revolving from the axial tilt of the
earth and how human beings have tracked
things throughout the throughout the
years and and everyone can make up their
own holidays but I said well what if
that dies with you in other words to
what do we owe past generations she's
standing mm-hmm okay yes where you fall
over backwards say no no I'm not
religious in any way okay I understand
the impulse
hey that I still identify atheistic Lee
mmm-hmm but I don't believe that my mind
knows that I'm an atheist
I believe that my mind is religious and
it was meant to be religious and it has
to do with possibly you know the
evolutionary basis so what do you do
with the parental reference once you're
just dispensed with parental since you
have to invested and shunt it somewhere
maybe it has to do with overlapping
generations so you don't become a
sociopath you have to watch then that
you don't become a religious sociopath
it's very complicated but I guess I'm
trying to get at is rationalists and
[Music]
people of the in the sort of less wrong
community will get rid of all of the
structure and then they'll spend their
time trying to reinvent it and they'll
go to Burning Man or Sunday assembly
right whatever and my feeling is cut it
out you know you're being ridiculous my
favorite challenge is if I told you that
you could be part of an ethnic group
that with one-quarter of 1% of the
world's population would win 25 percent
of the Nobel prizes in physics but it's
a religious ethnic group would you want
to get rid of the religion if it had
been such an incredible factor in terms
of a Bayesian prior as to who's likely
to succeed is that correlation or I mean
I I do believe I don't know but my point
is is that you would certainly not
casually say ah to hell with that
nonsense I know yeah you need to talk
about this on your podcast which I love
with Rabbi Walt B and you guys sure did
mention Nobel Prize a lot and you know
the thesis of my book is the Nobel Prize
sort of a worship idol worship avodah
Zarah as we say in Hebrew but but the
notion of you know everybody serves a
god I mean even if you're and I had this
debate with Lord Martin Rees and with
and with Freeman Dyson the late great
Freeman Dyson and he said you know I'm
basically agnostic and I said well
Freeman that's interesting but do you go
to church and and he's like no not
really
I said I'm like well so how would an
alien looking at Freeman Dyson know that
you're not an atheist you do the same
you go to the same church that Richard
Dawkins doesn't go to you know in other
words how do you just differentiate
yourself and you know he couldn't really
answer it was sort of this a little bit
mumbled thing and I do believe I'm
agnostic in the sense that I'm open I I
do
I do feel a tradition I'm not Orthodox I
always point that out because I don't
want Orthodox people to get you know the
wrong impression that I'm speaking on
their behalf in any way but I think you
and I do things that that at least
differentiate ourselves from true
atheist and so I think we can say were
atheist or agnostic or however but I
think that's sort of a natural place for
a scientist to be and that you're the
one thing Freeman did say that I did
agree with on the show that we did
together there was you know that God is
a great mystery and science is a great
mystery and what's more delicious than
solving mysteries and playing with
puzzles and I think he was a ponderer of
the highest order and I would say you
know it's good enough for Freeman Dyson
it's good enough for me I think it's an
interesting issue I think that they you
know what I would say is is that I'm a
time of a divided mind is almost all
religious people are of a divided mind
the moment that I identify with most
strongly is probably my a theistic
component but I think it would be
irrational to deny the other components
like I find faith everywhere in science
hmm has to do with probably an
evolutionary adaptation
given that I believe that my brains
architecture is predisposed towards
faith even though I may disagree with
that somewhere else you know it's a
little bit like weakness of will
problems where I know I don't want to
see that candy bar on the scale before
it sure looks tempting I don't
understand why people
can't talk about the fact that their
mind is doing things that they don't
understand we can't easily locate your
pancreas your body is kind of a mystery
you're its owner but you don't really
know how it works programs between your
ears that have never run that if you've
suddenly found yourself in a
life-and-death situation
like you've probably never gone seven
days with that food you probably don't
know right I've never seen the back of
my head in real Tony I'm just in the
back of your head and so I think that
partially the problem is that the
Atheist community in the rationale is a
trauma community and just the way I've
tried to own my trauma so people can say
okay I understand he had some bad
experiences and academics and in part
he's reacting to things that he's
actually been through maybe he's
carrying over things that are always
there but maybe the problem I think that
a lot of the rationalists and the less
wrong people are traumatized very often
you know I grew up in Jehovah's Witness
home and we were never allowed to
question no kidding now I understand a
lot more of where you are but any time
you see by rationale trap like you see
people who have had too much religion
flee toward atheism and you've had
people like me who grew up in a
completely atheistic setting right or
towards tradition in ritual and things
like timeshares in general people fall
into them but once they get out they
don't come back so my my feeling about
this has to do with a predatory
timeshares and there's any good time
sure the I think that in essence there's
a dialog about faith and reason and if
you you should know we're which one of
those places home is you don't invite
the other one in you're missing the
experience of being a human yeah my
friends in the atheist world freaked out
about this my friends in the religious
world know what it means to have crisis
of faith it's interesting that price
crisis of faith occurs as a reasonable
thing in the world of the religious
crisis of Reason just
have a name so much in the atheist world
and I don't know why that yeah you see
that there's a famous quote by a rabbi I
believe it is and he says something the
effect you know to the believer the
believer has to unexplained theodicy you
know the existence of evil and with a
good God but the the non-believer has to
explain everything else it's pithy it's
kind of cute but there is some truth to
that I look at Sam Harris a friend of
yours I've never met him but I've read
all his books and you know he goes to
great pains you know to basically
delineate what he's doing is not a
religion you know he doesn't believe the
Buddha was you know had complete
enlightenment and yet at the end you
know he's using all these terms and he's
using you know rema Vata whatever he's
using all the terms of Buddhism all the
cat catechisms that are inherent without
and I think you know I just see him and
I see like he's he's so conflicted and
he has he has just brilliant ideas and
one of them I want to get your opinion
on you probably heard him say this it's
from a flaw he's quoting and waking up
his book waking up he's quoting this
philosopher Derek Parfit and and I want
to talk to you in relative to your
philosophy on being a parent because I
don't think you've ever talked about
this on your podcast at least and I
can't resist the indulgence of the host
if you'll indulge me to ask you about
parenting but I want to I want to get
your take on this quote first so Santa
Harris quotes this philosopher Derek
Parfit he says imagine a spaceship you
have a few minutes Eric okay okay great
imagine a teleportation device that can
beam a person from Earth to Mars rather
than travel for many months on a
spaceship you need only enter a small
chamber close to home and push a little
green button and all the information in
your brain and body will be sent to a
similar station on Mars there you'll be
reassembled down to last Adam imagine
all your friends have done it all of
them seem fine and they describe the
experience as instantaneous relocation
you push the green button and you find
yourself standing on Mars that's
wonderful your most recent memory is of
pushing the green button and everything
happens fine so you decide to go to Mars
however in the process of arranging your
trip you learn a troubling fact about
the mechanics it turns out that the
technicians wait for your replica to be
built on Mars before obliterating his or
her original body this has the benefit
of leaving
I think a chance if something goes wrong
in the replication process no harm has
been done however it raises the
following concern while your double is
beginning his day or her day on Mars
with all your memories goals and
prejudices intact you'll be standing in
the teleportation chamber on earth just
staring at a green button
imagine a voice coming over the intercom
to congratulate you for arriving safely
at Mars in a few moments you'll be
obliterated how would this differ from
simply being killed and he relates us to
suicide but what I want to relate it to
is isn't that what kids are in some
sense like you're not going to be around
and I mean you want to be around for as
long as possible you know some of my
friends day to ask free wants to live to
be 180 you know in the biblical age that
Moses lived to is held to be the highest
standard 120 years but we the reality is
death stalks us all
I've used that quote you know in sam
Harris's book it's from this philosopher
Derek Peters I view it as kind of a
metaphor about parenting like you are
going to transmit into the future you're
not going to teleport in space perhaps
unless you know geometric unity has that
line within it but but but in fact we
are teleporting are are memes if you
will our ideas into the future and I
wonder what is your philosophy first of
all how do you react to that vignette
that thought experiment would you take
that chance would you push that button
and to what every night yeah that's
right well yeah we're still conscious
though right there know unconsciously I
wake up a new person and if I could
avoid it I think I wouldn't go to sleep
ever really okay what is your workday
like by the way what is your workflow
like is it the same every day to eat the
same food like Steve Jobs and wear the
same outfit
no I'm incredibly dysfunctional so it's
chaos every day is different
yeah every day I tried to get more chaos
into my life but there are people who
insist that it be less chaotic than I
would choose amusing to you but I'm
answering honestly I know I believe you
are so tell me about your theory of
parenting you're very you've spoken
about you know your
your relationship I guess with your
in-laws and obviously you've mentioned
your daughter although she has a private
personality and I want to talk anything
personal but what how do you view being
a father and and the relationship you
have with Pia and and how do you how do
you have a philosophy or is it everyday
like your daily life sounds like is a
new beginning interesting question
so are you a Tom Lehrer fan yep you
still there age now that stuff was so
over that sorry Erik I dropped Lee had
he dropped out for about 30 seconds you
said am i Tom Lehrer fan yes yeah
let me start again okay when you're
exposed to Tom Lehrer as a child all of
the naughtiness of the world is brought
to your to your feet and laid there and
I guess what I felt was that my
grandfather was part of this where he
showed me that the world wasn't the way
it was claimed to be and maybe it's an
intrinsically very Jewish thing to
constantly question the frame most
people did questions inside of a frame
and they answer the question to the best
of their ability and and Jews tend to
question the frame they spot the
argument what is my philosophy that you
should let your kid Drive well before
the age of 16 that you should make sure
that your children know what alcohol
tastes like in trace amounts to rob it
of its mystery and appeal that drugs
what what about drugs it is a drug what
about a hard schedule one drugs how do
you know obviously don't want them to
dabble in it or psychedelics like Sam
Maris somebody else could decide that
that was a good I mean I have
friend who's very well known I think
we've been trace amounts of schedule 1
substances you'd make a pretty MIT that
you schedule what substances are safer
mmm a certain physiological sense
personally do not favor getting
inebriated on drugs until your brain
it's pretty well developed mm-hmm so I
very much worry of the the purpose of
getting a trace amount of alcohol is to
say oh that's what Scotch tastes like
it's no longer something I need to sneak
to know you know so the the point isn't
that you get drunk when you're a kid or
you should get hot when you're a kid the
point is you should try to prevent your
children from becoming alcoholics and in
essence another piece of my philosophy I
guess is don't push your children
because you can any person can turn
their child into a prodigy there's an
emergency program in the mind of a child
that says if your parents die grow up
super fast and it it's you know it's
like a backup parachute if your first
parachute fails so don't push your
children but put everything in front of
them in case they're ready for something
super early I had a situation with my
son where my son was without question
the worst musician of all time bar none
could not do anything he was used to he
was musically hopeless and then before
he turned 13 in six weeks he taught
himself four instruments while I was
procrastinating for his Torah portion
and that told me a lot that even though
I had been dutifully putting it in front
of him and taking it away put in front
of take away the brain wasn't ready so
don't get into a thing where somebody
else's kid is you know one of my kids
walked and talked pretty young and the
other one did
get involved in competition about it
your child's brain is developing
according to its own path and neither
your child nor you will understand it
well enough
do not become your child's best friend
ever
yep there's plenty of us for yours you
are something far more important than
the best friend the best friend would be
a demotion if you're a parent so leave
that spot open in your child's life and
teach your children to break the rules
and teach them how take responsibility
for the breaking of the rules when you
break the rules it's not cheap mm-hmm so
you should teach them like if you're
gonna break the rules you you bought it
you broke it you bought it and you have
ownership and you better put more in the
till by the end of the day then you then
you chuck out and you have to think
about can I afford to take this money
out of the till and a my public spirit
and what if something goes wrong
hi agency you know there was just this
kid who apparently took the family sedan
from Utah to California he was five
years old and was pulled over on the
interstate because his parents forbid
him from buying a Lamborghini with the
lunch money and you know this
five-year-old kid is driving to
California successfully in the family
car I just thought I hope that kid
listens to the portal that's Mike that's
the future of America people all right
well it's funny as you're talking it
reminds me of a couple of dichotomies
that I've taken in my approach to Jewish
parenting although I'd say it applies to
anyone I mean what what our tradition is
known for it at most or at best baby is
our you know commitment to books into
and to really treasuring the the wisdom
of the elders not to say oh don't trust
anyone over 30 I mean we trust people
that are 30 centuries old and one of
those a statement in the Talmud which is
the dichotomy of raising kids and the
doula side of on one hand planting and
building and the Talmud speaks about
planting versus building and there's a
book by probably a relative of rabbi
Walt be named Schlomo wall be
and he has a book called planting and
building raising a Jewish child I think
I paused to any child whatsoever
non-jewish I always loved it by the way
that we talk about when a Jew talks
they'll say the [ __ ] you know it just
means nations but like as you said we're
0.2 percent of the world's population
like what other group there's a name for
non Scandinavia no it's just
non-standard avians like there's no
other word for it I always think that's
kind of cute but anyway these rules
apply I believe to any child and it's
this dichotomy between planting which is
like you fertilized soil and the kid has
a natural propensity to grow and develop
in a certain way on the other hand you
have to build and program into this
child a certain framework and structure
to fall back on but to that I'd add a
trichotomy Weinstein
you know Rabbi Weinstein would be would
be breaking so it's planting building
and breaking I think I agree
those are fundamentally you know I think
it's not like abusive parent if you
don't do it but nevertheless I think
that's really wonderful and I think also
to another just speaking of dualities I
want to get your impression rabbi Sol of
a chick famous a 19th century rabbis
into the 20th century had a statement
about the two different descriptions in
Genesis of Adam of the character Adam if
you believe I don't care people out
there believe it or don't take it
literally I don't but but you know
metaphorically there's two descriptions
of the same human being at least and one
is sort of you know what he was capable
of doing and you know he calls those
sort of the resume virtues but then it
speaks of his of his intrinsic qualities
and his nature to be in the image of God
or some transcendent being if God has
too loaded a word and he calls that the
eulogy virtues you know so to speak or
David Brooks ended up calling it that
and I wonder I mean do you feel like
there are those two sides and and do you
feel like there's any conflict between
these we have all these dualistic
natures like you said breaking verses
building or I said building and and then
resume virtues eulogy I wonder is one
more important or should we strive to
strike a balance between the two and
your opinions parents it's an
interesting question
I guess think a lot about the pajama
experiment and the discovery of the
operon so the DNA discovery had a very
clear visual but unfortunately grunt was
not as well known in biology it had to
do with regulated expression so in some
sense you have as you have wisdom but
sometimes you need to repress some
wisdom because it's not the right wisdom
for right now and sometimes you need to
promote some other wisdom that hasn't
run in a long time hmm so very often
what you have to understand it the code
is wrapped and it's like run this part
of the code under these circumstances
suppress this part of the code into
these other circumstances so this is why
there's an oral torah as well as a
written Torah why there's a Supreme
Court to interpret the oral Constitution
it is not found in the written
constitution and this is why there is
development is different from genetics
so it's kind of a through-line that
nobody notices and then people try to
resolve all that's textually and this is
what confuses me about my friend sam
harris more than the usual confusion
which is yes there's a lot of code and
what you need to do is bind repressor on
the stuff that says you know throw gays
off of off of cliffs which you know
might be found in the hadith or
something like that but in the in the
Jewish text in Deuteronomy it tells us
to set upon apostates with stones it's
very important that that code not run
even though it's in Deuteronomy you
don't have to remove it it's there for a
caution to describe the magnitude of the
transgression or maybe it's int it's a
quick code that now I you know there's
no evidence that it was ever run that's
right stoning the kid the rebellious son
right so in part I think the problem is
is that the paradigm of regulated
expression never made it to primetime
and every biology knows how important it
is and nobody outside thinks enough
about it but I would say that that's
really kind of the issue that you have
to express and this is the
of Ecclesiastes where there's time every
purpose under heaven when to run the
right code and when to think about the
potential and when to think about the in
physics and what was and what could have
been you know and I think you need a
Richard language of a paradigm in order
to capture it otherwise when you don't
have a sufficiently rich vocabulary of
paradigm you you spend your life as a
pendulum oscillating between
contradictory directives not
understanding that regulated expression
and superposition resolve most of the
dialect very interesting well I want to
turn to some lighter topics just to
finish up in the last few minutes things
I asked all my guests but before I do
that because I rarely have this chance
I'm gonna ask you to say you know true
or false and only say true or false and
if you can't answer because a true/false
or pass okay
okay I'm gonna take silence as agreement
as the Talmud says are there
extraterrestrial intelligences capable
of interstellar space travel yes or no
our paths are there extraterrestrial
intelligence
okay yes yes okay is there at least one
God that exists not necessarily sentient
but it might be a design constraint good
are you familiar with the simulation
hypothesis I am do you think it's not
the simulator okay Oh does it is it are
we in a simulation are we in the matrix
or you I know you're not neo but we are
both being the simulators it will give
rise to AGI and the simulated we do not
realize that if we put the two together
is really should God fear us becoming
emergently intelligently within the
world okay we are we are both the
simulated and simulate or haven't
connected the two stories do you think
the lifespan or health span of a human
being can be extended beyond 120 well
we've had one person lived to 120 223 so
that's trivially true
okay 180 potentially but you might not
as the Gershwin said who calls that
living when no gal would give in to no
man what nine hundred years and let's
see I think that wraps up the Oh what
just wrapping up with extraterrestrials
if you want to signal to an
extraterrestrial species that we are
worthy of peaceful visitation what would
you put on your interstellar billboard
to notify them of humanity's presence
and capabilities well I really like a
cdc's you shook me all night long but in
part because it uses the same four notes
that magically animate the SH MA that's
right very good we're gonna have a
minyan going soon okay now the last five
questions and then I will let you go sir
mm-hmm
so I think about people interacting with
our work that we do either usually have
authors on I want you to you know what I
might put the ceiling of lista grata the
media okay very well I've heard I've
heard worse choices so usually have
authors on I do want to encourage you
for many reasons not the least of which
you know we we never know when our when
our time is up and we have an obligation
as Jews as human beings I believe to
write what's called the sava and ethical
will
if you were to write a book or write an
ethical will summarizing your Gestalt
who you are for your children's
children's you know the reason I want
you to write a book is this question you
mentioned your great-grandfather let's
go one step further if you found out
your great-great-great grandmother wrote
thrilling autobiography in Eastern
Europe presumably and you could have it
you know is there any price you wouldn't
pay for such a document I think you're
great good good good grandchildren you
don't know who they are by definition so
I encourage you to write a book I do I
think it would be even without writing a
paper I think that would be the ultimate
if you wrote a book on your theory and
didn't write a paper but anyway because
then you can't up your age index then
your H index stays constant anyway who
would you rather engage with your book
you know that I'm gonna keep pestering
you badgering you to write or your your
theories and your thoughts people that
are a you know kind of accepting of your
work or people that are nemesis haters
skeptics my work will work its course oh
my feeling about it is I'm not worried I
think I will have said what I needed to
say and if people want to fight it in my
lifetime or they want to accept it
there'll be a certain amount of whatever
what I am very focused upon is let's
assume that it's right if it's right I
would like people to listen to all the
other crazy things I have to say after
they've piled on with their vitriol
their nonsense their animus because
nothing would give me greater joy than
to have people get me completely wrong
on the first time and then realized that
what I was trying to say about saving
ourselves and being better stewards was
it was heartfelt meaningful and the idea
that Einstein got to write ideas and
opinions because of the field equations
even of though almost nobody knows the
field equations they have a sense that
month he must have been on to something
important so if my stuff turns
to be right I would like the rest of
what I've been saying you take it
seriously and thankfully I've been able
to leave a lot of it is audio yeah
because I'm an ear mouth person rather
than an eye hand first right dysgraphia
and other challenges you've overcome
okay this brings me to my last you know
kind of standard question that I ask all
my guests in one form or another it's a
quote by Ciaran Kirk søren kierkegaard
who said that life can only be
understood backwards but it must be
lived forwards what I want to ask you is
what thing in your life at age 20 was
perplexing and and then makes sense now
through the lens of time experience
wisdom you know say science means
knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom so now
that you've accumulated wisdom what
thing would you tell your 20 year old
self that seemed impossible and then
venturing into the impossible gave you
clarity and into the reality of this
aspect of your nature well it's gonna be
very it's gonna sound very specific but
it actually governs all of our lives I
was astounded by the brutality
indifference cruelty of my elders and I
did not understand the extent to which
the entire world changed in the early
1970s in a structural fashion there is
now up sight I I wouldn't put it exactly
1971 sometimes he's been in 1971 and
1973 the world changed character in a
way that can be easily seen I think it's
called WTF happened in 1971 if you want
an introduction it's somebody else's
version I did not understand that my
entire life as an adult would be lived
in a bubble dominated by generations
that cannot come to grips with the fact
that the world changed structurally and
punishing those of us who came after
them forcing us to live in a simulation
of the world before 1971 through 73
that we are eventually going to have to
pay for and for example when I started
working for Peter Thiel it was a guy who
has many of my opposite characteristics
you'd never think we'd get along but
he's slightly younger than me by a year
or two and I always thought I had a
problem with authority and I thought I
had a problem working for other people
and more or less we've gotten on great
for seven years and the reason in part
is is that I only worked for people
considerably older than I was or under
and I realized that this is just a very
serious dividing line and that this is
bubble which began initially in the fall
of 1945 when World War two ended and
ended I think On February 19th of this
year 2020 when the market figured out
that Corona was going to be a big deal
been a 75 year interruption of reality
and in particular the power nap was
between 1945 and 1970 through 73 and the
rest of the time after the interregnum
in 73 on has been this bubble of
complete unreality I think most people
that I know don't realize that they've
grown up in the Truman Show it's a
universal Truman Show and it's cracking
this is the end of it and so you know in
an interesting example inside of the
university system is look at the career
of Norman steam rod on the math
genealogy project a guy whose he advised
his last advisee 1972 right when this
thing changed and all of the students go
on to become professor it's impossible
for everybody to train professors to
become professors and they have 20
students but they're 22 higher and
higher powers and you see the explosion
and so in essence we have been growing
up in a simulation of a world we have
never seen and the intergenerational
stuff is so far thrown
that we were actually considering having
an election between a 74 year old man
and a 77 year old man when previously
you know one before Trump Ronald Reagan
was the oldest president ever to take
the oath and inauguration was 69 this is
not believable and if we do not realize
that we are going to have to pay the
bills of our grandparents and parents
and we have no resources to do it we are
spinning out of control it is time to
recognize as much as we love these
people they have led us into a very
dangerous place far away from reality we
found out that we don't manufacture our
own masks we can't get tests we don't
have reagent we are sitting ducks there
is no government effective there is no
ability to convene smart people there's
no place that we can we can have a
Manhattan Project for anything because
we can't have smart people asking
questions because everyone's too busy
looting so I think that this concept of
Babylon that we live in comes from a
change in growth regime that happened
between let's say 1971 through 73 and
just like the period between 1952 and 54
where you have DNA and the hydrogen bomb
everything changes sometimes over a tiny
period of years so if I if I ask myself
when I was growing up why are these old
people so horrible I would have
understood that what happened was that
they've been locked into a Ponzi scheme
which is structural and they weren't
courageous enough to stop it
and that it wasn't coming out of
personal cruelty it was coming out of
the fact that they just couldn't imagine
that they should live in any different
circumstances than they did well Eric I
want to thank you for that discussion
has been incredible I will certainly
refer people to all the different sites
I'll point out that that site is WTF
happened in 1971 and I know that one of
the things that happened is very
important to me because that's the year
I was born so it's not listed on the
chart but it was has some importance to
me well also the standard model more or
less
put in place and I don't that's right
and some date that as you know sort of
controversially speaking is the end of
of the of the high growth period now I
mean what you're saying is in direct
opposition to a guest I had on recently
Peter Diamandis who kind of views you
know the future is getting rosier all
the time along with his friend Ray
Kurzweil and the so called popularizer
of the singularity hypothesis that were
going into this realm of abundance and
you've heard this in the heat speaks in
the material world you've heard this
from Steven Pinker and even Michael
Shermer
and in terms of you know the better
angels of our nature and and rationality
now and etc and I wonder you know how
you react to those you know hypotheses
that basically are you know conjecturing
something completely opposite that seems
a very simple yeah if you if you don't
have a potential energy term you don't
get conservation of energy inside of a
physical system you don't have a
potential horror term I guarantee
everything is getting better as mister
as dr. Pinker says but the problem is
the singularity already happened it was
predicted by Derek the soul of Christ at
Yale and around 1959 it came true in
about 1971 through 73
it wasn't the singularity in the diamond
diam and his perks while are talking
about and Pinker can be explained by
making sure that you neglect the fact
that the potential horror has his
version of kinetic horror so yes it
appears that there is a weird free lunch
but if you'll think about the blast
radius of a hydrogen device superimposed
on your favorite metropolitan area you
will find that in fact there is a price
to be paid for this piece in this
prosperity you've talked about the cell
in the atom and these two different
nuclei problem yeah and you know the
problem is is that Pinker will appear to
be right until the AH is impressed
this is my friend in the scene talev is
fond of saying the farmer is awfully
good to the turkey right up through the
end of November that's right
or the vegan friends the the pumpkin is
treated well by the pumpkin farmer until
the end of October well Eric I want to
thank you so much you're a real Mensch
and I do want to extend invitation for
you to visit and I'm not you know this
is totally sincere I'm inviting you in
front of the you know tens of thousands
of people who listen to this and you
know after this podcast it's gonna be
good for you because between my show and
Joe Rogan show you will been seen by
like six million and one people so
that's really I think great credit for
that but but I do want to extend to you
in all seriousness an opportunity not
just to meet with me as I would treasure
but but also to meet with my colleagues
who work on experiments these are people
like Elena up real and and and Connie
and Frank worth and other people here
and there they are mentioned like you
and and and I think you will you will
derive great benefit from talking with
these wonderful folks because I think
the truest sign of respect is when we
challenge each other in but it has to be
in a good natured fashion it cannot be
for vindictiveness ad hominem attacks
and that's you know just to circle back
to the beginning it really set me off I
know you don't need me to defend you in
any way but it set me off that there
were ad hominem things being raised
about you about Stephen Wolfram and and
you know I challenge him I challenge you
here and there today I think it's
important where did you see these so
there's tweets I can send you there are
there are reddit fora that that speak
about this they're you know mostly it's
these you know people on the on the
social media so so the original one was
obliquely you know mentioning mentioning
that you know the the degree of
credulity expressed at a theory by Sean
Carroll of something presented on you
know tick-tock or on a podcast should be
taken you know quite low where you know
unless it's published in a paper perhaps
you know he didn't respond directly and
say your name but there are others who
you know
precised you specifically and I can I
can send you that but but again it's
it's the same kind of you know publisher
it didn't happen and referee Shawn was
it wrong hmm this point was very
carefully phrase effect on the inference
you could tell that he was pissed yeah
but he was careful and saying not that
this can't be true correct but that the
Bayesian prior should tell you that
something is wrong
Shawn carefully avoids me in many
different ways
his wife less so but I think that the
Shawn at his best is trying to perform a
service for the world so that it does
not become confused I wish you would
perform the same service for string
theory because he has been relatively
friendly to a much more dangerous theory
if you look at the number of an hours
that have been spent ring theory if you
look at the number of PhDs wasted the
cost the string theory is astronomical
relative in its cost to eat there
Wolfram's theory or to my theory the
problem is selective application of the
rules you have a a speed limit that is
enforced against black motorists and not
enforced against white motorists you
have to ask yourself the question why
the asymmetric enforcement I don't think
that what Shawn is saying is wrong at a
technical level and the great pleasure
would be to show that unlikely is not
the same thing as definite yeah fair
enough
well Eric it's a pleasure to spend so
much time with you I thank you for your
graciousness and willingness to come on
and speak with us I do I will keep
badgering you to both write a book and
to visit San Diego in the near future I
accept them the letter okay well I'll
try to work on I have ways of making you
write Eric bit of pleasure have a
wonderful rest of your day
no you got to get on to other stuff
thank you so much for spending time with
us dr. Keating thank you for giving me
the opportunity to talk to with your
listeners and it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
imagine
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent
guests newest book send a screenshot of
your review to info at imagine UCSD edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination UCSD edu find us on
Twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
YouTube listen on iTunes in to the
impossible is a production of the arthur
c-- clark center for human imagination
in the division of physical sciences at
the University of California San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco